Arak I'm sure many of you automatically
associate this word this name with a
destroyed country that's ravaged by war
a place with no hope or future a place
where religious extremism runs wild and
there are endless conflicts between
Sunnis and Shiites and you know what
you'd be absolutely right this has been
Iraq's reality for the last few decades
especially following the first Gulf War
the US invasion and the emergence of the
Islamic state the terrorist group which
ended up occupying a large part of the
country we're talking about a place that
is a factory for bad news without
delving too deep in the last few months
strong social revolts have caused a lot
of tension the Iraqis are unhappy and
for good reason RAK at least 42 dead and
2,000 injured in anti-government
protests Iraq protests capital Baghdad
blocked as unrest escalates
[Music]
however this time we're not going to
talk about a destroyed Iraq or disasters
or about victims or indeed about
misfortune if you're a regular viewer of
this channel you've probably realized by
now but we'd like to look at the bright
side of things too and it's precisely in
this video right here on visual politic
that we're going to try and show the
side that no one ever talks about when
it comes to Iraq and that's it's good
side but does this country really have
an upside what would you think if I told
you that even though this country still
has loads of problems and is light years
away from being a good place to live
there are still plenty of reasons to be
optimistic well listen up
[Applause]
it's time to look at some history after
all we can't was understand today's Iraq
without taking a look at their past at
least the country's more recent past in
2003 after Saddam Hussein and his regime
fell following the US invasion a state
of chaos and the lack of
institutionality emerged that continues
to this day after the US occupation an
interim government was established for a
year and then a transitional government
was in charge between May 2005 and May
2006 there was this transitional
government that drafted the current
constitution however despite all these
attempts for political normalization the
country's governance was virtually
impossible and it was precisely in this
highly conflictive environment with
institutions that were unable to
function and a complete lack of safety
that jihadist militias increased the
influence and power that is how
extremism boomed which resulted in
numerous attacks that of course caused
huge amounts of damage and greatly fuels
the anti-western sentiment amongst a
good part of the population
[Applause]
of course the United States and his
allies hadn't only occupied the country
they were unable to bring order to it
and had turns the Iraqi city streets
into Hornets nests that's why the people
who perceived international troops
negatively were no longer just the
supporters of Saddam Hussein's regime
but were a much wider range of people
and it was precisely this rejection of
the West which grew slowly and explains
news stories like this one Iraq anti-us
cleric moqtada al-sadr x' bloc confirmed
as election winners so is Iraq at risk
of becoming a new Iran well let's not
get ahead of ourselves then let's go
back to 2014 that year an Iraqi man Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi leader of the Islamic
state jihadist group declared his own
Caliphate world caliph aids on Iraqi
lands he came to be considered a
successor of muhammad and his corps
mobilised vast numbers of militants the
restoration of the caliphate who learns
at the beginning of a huge military
offensive by isis where heinous crimes
were committed while capturing huge
amounts of lands even important iraqi
cities like Mosul or Fallujah fell under
their power and with that the most
recent reign of terror had been created
[Music]
and we all know this story especially
now that the United States has confirmed
that it has eliminated Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi he died like a dog he died like
a coward the fact is that since 2014 the
defeat of Isis became the number-one
priority of both the Iraqi government as
Iraq was held against the ropes due to
Isis's advance and also the United
States government's as well as of course
the Kurds who we discussed in depth in a
recent video
[Music]
and of course faced with this challenge
all of the Iraqi government's efforts
were focused on defeating the Islamic
state everything else just drifted into
the backgrounds as you can imagine this
meant Iraq social and economic advances
were paralyzed for a very long time who
would dare to invest in a shattered
country there was also being invaded by
Isis barbarians the worst part is that
despite all their efforts and help from
the West the threat of Isis still hasn't
disappeared even though the Caliphate
has been dismantled Isis is regaining
strength in Iraq and Syria
[Music]
but hold on just a second at the
beginning of this video we did promise
that we weren't going to talk about the
bad side of Iraq in fact we said we were
going to talk about the opposite and
it's hard to find positive things in a
place like Iraq but believe me there are
some the fact is that after the
caliphates fall the iraqi institutions
have been strengthened and security has
greatly improved this is made Iraq begin
to take a few steps forward
[Music]
Jameses arrived better late than never I
don't think anyone would doubt the
difficulty of rebuilding a country that
has practically been at war since 1980
it's almost 40 years it's a situation
that not only didn't improve with the US
invasion that actually got worse after
the occupation and the violence that
broke out Baghdad became a city divided
by large walls military controls and
road blocks everywhere mobility in the
city was very very difficult to give you
an idea it took hours to cross the city
by car because of the huge number of
detours and controls that you had to
cross the city looked more like a
gigantic military base than a country's
capital citizens lived at virtually
kidnapped existence curfews were common
and it wasn't even safe to go outside
for tea or coffee
Baghdad condemned you to a terrible life
and in many cases a pretty short one
however after the defeat of the Islamic
state caliphate in Iraq things have
begun to improve by leaps and bounds
check this out
to turn the situation around one of the
key measures that the Iraqi government
has implemented has been the plan to
eliminate all military checkpoints
obstacles and interior walls that
separated neighborhoods from each other
after 15 years of living with these
elements Baghdad's population has
experienced worrying social changes
mostly a result of isolation the
isolation of the neighborhoods created
closed communities which barely had
contact with other communities within
the city this led to an increase in
violence and rejection among the
different groups once access was
restored
and to combat this the first step to
take is evidence Rack lives nearly 30
kilometres of blast walls from Baghdad
official Iraq plans to remove 300
checkpoints erect security fence in
Baghdad quote more than 600 streets will
be opened up in Baghdad and all concrete
blocks will be removed from streets in
order to ease traffic jam end quote
[Music]
imagine how I would have been to live in
Baghdad in the last decade it would've
been a true nightmare but the changes
don't just end with the capital so
what's happening in other parts of Iraq
is it as significant as they say
[Music]
emerging from between two opposite poles
even though it may be hard to believe
there is more good news on the horizon
for Iraq it looks like things are
starting to function again public works
have increased housing construction is
at its highest level in recent decades
and crude oil production is skyrocketing
Iraq's oil production has nearly doubled
over the past decade according to OPEC
crude oil exports have grown to around
3.8 million barrels per day allowing
Iraq to make almost 70 billion dollars
in 2018 Iraq is pumping record oil
creating a fully blown migraine for OPEX
cutting plans the problem stems from the
fact that the relationship between the
central government and the
semi-autonomous region of Iraqi
Kurdistan which also happens to be where
a large part of the closet's can be
found is frankly a rather bad and in
fact one of the reasons for this tension
is oil in Iraq all exports depends
heavily on the Kurdish region the
central government and the Kurds share
oil revenues and sometimes this ends up
serving as a political weapon for each
side in order for them to put pressure
on each other but this isn't the main
reason for their bad relationship the
real trigger was the Iraqi Kurdistan
independence referendum which we
discussed previously right here on this
channel
[Music]
without a doubt one of the things that
has aroused the most fears and
misgivings and investors and the
international community has been the
relationship between Baghdad and Tehran
so yes in Washington they must be
pulling their hair out you invade a
country you spend a fortune you have a
lot of casualties and in the end that
country ends up in the hands of one of
your greatest enemies it's all pretty
crazy iran-backed militias are here to
stay
Iran dominates Iraq after us quote
handed the country over end quote
so that's how it is well though to be
fair we should state that Iran's
influence seems to have lost a bit of
steam in recent years this may be due to
among other things enormous pressure
from Saudi Arabia but even so we're
talking about a relationship that puts
many political leaders around the world
especially in Washington on edge you see
a union comprised of these two countries
Iran and Iraq joined together would lead
to an alliance that would have combined
reserves of more than 300 billion easy
to exploit oil barrels this would be the
largest conventional oil reserve in the
world it's more than the reserves of
Saudi Arabia or Venezuela we're talking
about an alliance that with 120 million
inhabitants and such natural resources
could easily become the greatest power
in the Middle East once more we're
talking about two Shiite majority
countries two of the three Shiite
majorities in the world
the other one is Azerbaijan
and don't think I need to remind you
that's in that area of the world
religious ties are extremely important
while the fact is that in modern-day
Iraq there are at least 30 armed groups
most of them Iran supporters who make up
these so-called popular mobilization
forces these paramilitary forces of no
less than 125,000 troops
125,000 troops over which Tehran holds
very important influence and this is
something that the Iraqi government
itself has tried to curb but in all
honesty haven't really been very
successful first the armed groups were
invited to leave their loyalty to Iran
in order to join the Iraqi armed forces
and now they're trying to do it by force
which is put in the country on alert
again getting rid of one no need to get
saddled with another some countries just
seem doomed death toll soar as pro Iran
militias accused of shooting protesters
now is precisely due to this wave of
violence that the Iraqi government is
now trying to put more distance between
themselves and the Iranian regime and to
look more towards Riyadh instead that is
the Iraqi government's new strategy and
who once we aren't talking about
military issues
[Music]
Saudi Arabia makes inroads in Iraq to
curb Iranian influence the state-owned
oil company Aramco the chemical company
sounded basic industries and the mining
company Mardan are just a few of the big
Saudi corporations that are looking to
set up in Iraq by establishing joint
ventures or making direct and indirect
investments in Iraqi companies moreover
Saudi Arabia opens another consulate in
Baghdad at the beginning of April 2019
accompanied by an aid package worth 1
billion dollars and that's not all
because at the end of October 2019 King
Salman and Iraqi Prime Minister Marty
Nets in Saudi Arabia and signed at least
13 agreements related to trade energy
and political cooperation
yes it looks like the Iraqi government
wants to take advantage of the Arab cold
war to get their share and flood the
country with dollars makes sense
wouldn't you think now will the popular
mobilization forces allow this or will
they once again unleash a campaign of
violence and terror to stabilize the
country for another decade and will Iraq
finally succeed and take the leap
towards stability and development well
we hope so so I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos and
please do check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast who provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you next time
[Music]